Ready,
boom,
and we're live.
What's up man?
How's it going?
Pleasure to meet you.
Finally.
Get you.
Yeah,
man.
I'm a fucking huge fan of yours.
Oh,
well,
thank you very much.
I listened to your,
the last album.
I've listened to that fucking thing
hundreds of times.
I'll listen to it all the time when I'm
headed to the comedy store,
puts me in a good mood.
Less good.
That's what music is supposed to do.
I just stunned by the fact that for the
longest time you were basically doing
the songwriting thing.
You were doing a lot of that.
You were making your own music,
but you were known more as a songwriter.
Yeah.
He will,
you know,
you walked through the doors that are
open,
so you do the things that come up and,
and uh,
you know,
somewhere in the middle of that you find
out what your thing is.
You know,
God damn your voice is so good,
man.
I mean,
I don't want a fan boy out on you,
but it's just such a classic like male
voice singing those kinds of songs.
It's like,
I'm glad someone's still doing it.
Right.
Oh,
well I don't.
I don't know,
you know.
Thank you.
I'll also say thank you.
I don't want to say I'm doing it right
and somebody else is doing it wrong.
Well for me,
I'm doing what I do.
You Bill what you do?
I like,
so I'm,
I'm just happy that someone out there
doing what you're doing.
Thank you.
And uh,
what,
what is going on with you right now?
You've got a new album's about to come
out.
Got a new album that's a,
came out December first and yeah,
we're proud of it and hope people like
it because it on itunes and all that
jazz.
Yeah.
You can get it at where that music is
available as far as I know that that's
what they tell me.
So how does the doors opened up for you
now?
Is Everything feel like,
yeah,
we're sitting here talking to them.
No.
Yeah,
I mean beyond good.
Good would be the understatement of the
century for,
for,
you know,
just so many things that sound like fake
fake life.
Yeah.
You know,
things that happen in phone calls,
you get people you meet,
people you to talk to and like what?
Shoot man,
just any of it.
Just,
you know,
getting to go play.
This past year we played three shows
with Tom Petty and the heartbreakers
Oh man.
You know,
that must have been amazing.
It was amazing.
We played Wrigley field with Tom Petty
and the heartbreakers Holy Shit.
It was just that,
I don't know,
it was a bunch,
but it,
it felt just as cool as it sounds like
it should man.
Wrigley field with Tom Petty and the
heartbreakers.
It doesn't get any cooler than that.
Not to me.
It doesn't,
you know,
but maybe there's,
maybe there's something else.
So how long has success been happening?
Like two years now.
Um,
to,
to the degree that it's happening right
now,
you know,
probably since 2015.
A couple of couple of years of good,
strong.
We're going on three of,
you know,
doing,
playing shows it to more people than we
knew ever came to la show.
So yeah,
it's been a know,
a strange life altering thing when you
hear it.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
please welcome Chris Stapleton and
what is that like?
Freak you out?
What?
We don't usually do them money,
announcements like that.
We just kind of walk out there and play.
That's the move.
Yeah,
we don't,
we don't hype him up.
You have to too much.
We just kind of walk out there and fire
up a.
That might be the way to do it.
Well,
I mean it's.
Everybody has their own thing,
but I don't have like a hype guy doing
that.
You need like the kiss God.
God that's bad in the world.
I remember that when I was a kid.
I go and see kiss live a bunch of times.
You get so fucking pumped up at the
beginning because they would go through
the hottest band in the world.
I've never seen Kish live,
but Jane Simmons did show up to a show
of ours wants weirdest thing ever.
He said we were in New York somewhere
and he just happened to be in town.
He played the night before wherever we
were playing and he showed up and just
to say hi and here's Gene Simmons on the
side of the state before we go play our
Gig and I'm just like,
you know,
really?
Yeah.
It's one of those,
one of those models were talking about.
You asked about people.
That was one of them.
It's just like,
hi.
Hi.
Gene Simmons.
Gene Simmons came to see me one time a
few years back at New Year's Eve at the
Improv,
him and his family to see me.
New Year's Eve.
I was fucking legitimately nervous the
whole time.
You're looking at Jane [inaudible]
going,
yeah,
we're not looking at him,
you know,
one way or the other.
You know,
it was so odd.
It was like,
you know who I am?
Fuck,
is that possible?
It's strange stuff,
man.
So this phrase,
but I love talking to people that are
like a year,
two years into the situation you're in
right now where he just kind of getting
settled into it where it still seems
like fantasy land.
I'm not sure that it would ever not seem
like fantasy land because I spent enough
years not in fantasy land to realize
that it's in fantasy land.
You could be,
you could be like 71 day on cocaine,
15 ex wives,
just gotta hope not.
That sounds horrible,
but it seems like it happens to a lot of
folks.
Right?
Well maybe.
I hope not me.
Yeah,
I hope not.
Youtube.
I mean you seem like you could avoid.
It seems like a horrid,
horrid existence.
Well,
there's a balancing act I think with any
great musician or any great artist
really is like doing the art and then
now you're,
you're in the Olympics.
Like you're in this,
this weird thing where you know you're
gonna win grammys and you're going to
have platinum albums if they still have
those anymore and you're going to be on
these talk shows and people are gonna
read it.
It's a different animal now.
Well,
yeah.
I mean yes and no.
For me,
I mean I,
I,
I still,
whatever we have is because we
concentrate on the music and when music
lead and so try to do anything other
than that,
you know,
I'll have fun with some of the stuff,
go get somebody wants me to do a bit on
the show or something,
I'm fine with that,
that's cool.
But it's still all just comes from
music,
you know,
and it's all,
the focus is always going to be the
music and anything other than that,
you know,
there was never in my mind and he
focused on trying to stay famous.
Does that makes sense?
And I knew you were going to think like
that.
Yeah,
I'm very happy.
Sad.
No,
I didn't.
I don't make music for that reason.
And in order to win awards or anything
like that,
um,
I make it because I like it and hope
that it's good.
Well,
I think it was very clear in your music
itself that does what you're dealing
very clear.
It's very clear that that's pure,
that it's just this is what you do and
you're concentrating on that.
It's not,
there's nothing disingenuous about it.
There's nothing pumped up.
Fake or.
Well,
yeah,
I hope not,
you know,
I know,
right.
That's the.
Yeah.
But I mean it's gotta be a weird world.
I mean,
the world of the music business is very,
very strange world.
I've talked to a lot of musicians and
you know,
navigating the world of commerce and
music and
there again,
I,
you know,
I always,
if you just simplify it down to let the
music lead and let that kind of be
always the focus for me that makes it
real easy to not make what decisions you
would regret or,
or feel like weren't you.
So as long as that's the focus,
that's okay.
You know,
all that other stuff just kind of
becomes,
you know,
external noise that will all,
it doesn't matter,
you know,
it's not a,
it's not a hard thing to navigate in
that realm to me,
to you,
to me.
No,
but you must see it being a difficult
thing for some folks.
You now,
right?
Uh,
sometimes you know,
some people,
but some people,
um,
you know,
care very much about
him.
This is the first,
you're the first person to ever get me
in dangerous waters.
Like I'm talking about people.
We don't have to name names,
I don't want to sound judgemental.
And what I'm saying,
my wife calls this pulling back the
curtain too much.
She's like,
don't pull back that curtain too much,
but you know,
if you want to pull it back,
I know that you,
like,
you're the guy that likes to pull back
the curtain.
I think it's good to look back there
sometimes.
Fuck,
the monsters are up to.
Well yeah,
I mean I think,
I think uh,
if you,
if you roll up into the music business
or you know,
this is my experience,
if you roll up into one to make records
and wanting to be in the music business
and wanting to make a living,
playing music,
uh,
having absolutely no opinion of what you
want to do or who you are,
how you do it,
and you want everybody else to tell you
how to do it and what to do.
And when and where,
and why,
then yeah,
it can be a confusing thing because
there will be a lot of external opinions
that aren't yours,
that will create someone that is not
you,
that you will have to play for the rest
of your life.
So it was that.
So,
uh,
you know,
but as long as you're doing things that,
that are you and do come,
you know,
from you and from who you are and what
you'd like to do that that's never wrong
decision.
And sometimes that doesn't add up to
most times it doesn't add up to some
kind of commercial success.
But,
uh,
you know,
at least you can look at yourself in the
mirror on it and not hate whatever it is
you have to go out and play.
Right.
Let's see.
So it can become my artistic equivalent
of like a soulless corporate job where
you just kind of get sucked into
something.
You want to be doing it for a living.
Maybe it makes you money,
but you never really get to be yourself
because you're sort of programmed into
this thing that they've sort of
manufactured.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well,
a or an or you ignore it.
Some other passion or talent that you
have
under the guise of it seeming risky or
irresponsible and try to do,
go do this thing that seems like in your
mind is the normal thing to do.
Like when Garth Brooks put on that wig
and pretended to be that other dude,
remember that part?
I remember that thing to remember.
The love that I love when someone goes
like,
Whoa,
way off the reservation.
Well,
I think the story was that,
and I don't know if this is true or not,
that there was supposed to be like a
movie.
Yeah,
they did a documentary.
They did a behind the music.
Is that about this fake guy?
But I think.
I think the idea was that we're supposed
to be a movie here it is.
And then.
And then like this was supposed to be
like the soundtrack,
but I think the mistake if there was a
mistake,
and I'm not going to try to discuss
research and career in the realm of
making mistakes,
well you know,
who am I to judge anybody?
Typically somebody who is as successful
as he is,
but I'd love.
I got friends in low places.
I love a lot of garth's music.
I'm not a garth brooks hater.
I think that was a colossal fuck up.
That I think is hilarious and if God's
was here,
I'd pull that up and I would tell him I
loved him and I would say,
come on dude.
What the fuck were you smoking back
then?
Like who talked you into this?
You know,
I will say,
I think at the time that he did that,
he had to be into what in the world else
can I do?
The only way I can become more
successful is if I become someone else
and make them successful.
He was so successful and still is in
that space that he can't be any bigger
than he is like Stephen King when he
used to write as Richard Bachman.
Do you remember that?
No,
I don't.
I'm not aware of this.
Yeah.
He wrote a bunch of books under a
pseudonym because he was so gigantic
that he decided to write some books
under a different name so that people
would sort of appreciate the work for
what it was instead of as a Stephen King
book,
I think.
Or just maybe even as an exercise.
Right.
Well,
I think very much that's what it is.
I would look at it very much the same
way.
Of course it's kind of hard when it's
your face up there to put a mask on.
Something should have got like Rick
Baker to do them up with a fake nose,
you know,
completely.
You know?
Yeah.
Well make like an ugly weathered look in
Saddle Warren Dude,
put a seal wig on and go.
Yeah.
But it was a.
They had a behind the music story on his
life store and the drugs and all the
problems and the moodiness and you know,
but the music was always there and it's
a hilarious behind the,
behind the music.
You could watch it on youtube.
I highly recommend it.
Okay,
well I will watch it on Youtube.
I haven't seen that particular thing,
but he's pulled himself out of that.
He had a giant long hiatus and here's an
interesting thing about garth brooks.
He can't get his shit on itunes.
Oh No.
You have to get it on whatever his CD or
whatever.
Then there's also his personality.
He had something called ghost tunes for
a minute,
I think.
Was that the name of it?
It was like his own curated streaming
service where you stream only garth
brooks tunes or something like that.
I don't know.
I remember something about that.
Well,
I think his idea is that he wants his
albums played from there to as ghost
tunes.
He wants his albums played from the
first song to the last.
He doesn't want like little bits and
chunks.
He doesn't want to sell his songs
individually.
This is what I believe I've read that he
liked.
He thinks of his albums as one
continuous work and while I,
you know,
I as much as anybody can understand that
and want very much people to listen to
things as bodies work,
but in the world we're living in,
you know,
sometimes you gotta let people skip over
a song here,
let people do whatever they want with
me.
You did.
I don't want control people's right
thing.
Yeah.
And sometimes it's just a song that gets
them.
And that song,
if you sell that song individually,
that'll get them and then maybe they'll
check.
All right,
well listen to this 100 times.
What else Chris got to say?
Yeah,
maybe.
I don't know.
So how did you get a quote unquote
discovered as a singer?
Did you,
you started off as a songwriter,
but you were always singing.
I was singing,
I was in bluegrass bands.
I was in rock bands touring,
you know,
in a pickup truck or something like
that.
You know.
How old are you?
I'm 39.
And how many years did you do that for?
A.
Well,
I moved to Nashville when I was 23 and
probably the first three years I was in
town,
I only wrote three times a day living,
eating,
sleeping,
breathing,
songwriting,
trying to learn how to do that,
you know,
in a way that kept me a job at a
publishing company.
So,
so how does that work when you get
signed by a publishing company or you
get a job at a publishing company
writing while you have your contract
labor deal,
basically it's like you have a,
you sign a deal with,
you know,
like you got a year and they get an
option or two to pick it back up for
another couple of years.
You know,
what,
if one of those songs hits,
uh,
you know,
those terms were worked out,
whether you have,
what percentage of publishing they have,
a percentage that you have and they pay
you a salary in exchange for,
you know,
because they're lucrative.
It can be,
yeah,
it can be,
you know,
if you have a bunch of songs on the
radio and so for you was,
you were getting by doing this.
Well,
I know I've made a very comfortable
living up to the point
about and what that allowed me to go out
and play bluegrass for next to no money
or no play rock and roll and,
and have fun doing it and not worried
about that being how I'm making a
living,
you know,
but I've got to do it for the right
reasons.
And so in a lot of ways,
you know,
the songwriting thing,
the commerce pay for the art I guess in,
in which I am a firm believer.
And then some people were arguing this
is a conversation that struggle and I
will have the commerce paying for the
art.
But yeah.
So yeah,
it's a,
it's a great thing.
It still is.
I,
you know,
I still write songs for people.
I still write with people when they
asked me to do that for because it's
cool to get into somebody else's head,
you know,
or a kind of sit down with them and try
to help them realize some vision of what
it is they want to do.
And that's still one of my favorite
things to do.
And I'm just as interested in that as I
am in and doing my own thing a lot.
Wow.
So when you learn how to write music,
um,
did you,
when you would write,
will you sit,
do you sit down with an idea in mind
with a guitar?
Do you sit down with a pen and pad?
Like how do you,
how do you write songs?
Well,
if I'm riding by myself or with somebody
else because there's a lot of different
processes it can be,
you know,
whatever comes up that day for me.
Generally,
if I was just going to say,
Hey,
I'm going to sit down and go over in
that corner and write a song,
I'd have a guitar,
I'd probably have a legal pad and a pen
much likely have sitting right here.
And I'd start strumming until that felt
like something.
And how does that make me feel?
I don't know.
Keep started humming the melody maybe.
And hopefully somewhere in humming.
The melody of word would pop out that
are noise.
I would turn into a word.
And from there you can kind of grow this
thing into whatever it is supposed to
be.
Now that that's how I would do it if I
was sitting around by myself.
Now there's other times you and I could
be having a conversation and you could
say a phrase or a line or,
or I could read a sign going down the
road.
You know,
if you're a songwriter,
you're always writing songs.
It's not like a choice that you have.
It's like a,
an affliction that you have in some way.
So you just kind of walking around a
unconsciously things will hit you,
you know,
and,
or moments will hit you or visual were
hit you.
And that will spark something.
So that's,
that's really,
um,
it can come from anywhere.
And that's.
And that's the truth.
It sounds a lot like writing comedy.
I'm sure I don't,
I personally cannot write comedy,
but I'm,
I would think the creative process is
very much the same.
You know,
you're trying to kind of take life and
distilled into something,
you know,
that evokes an emotional response.
Do you sometimes sit down with a blank
slate?
Like you have no idea what you want to
talk about or write about.
Absolutely.
And that's,
and that's back to the publishing deal
thing.
That's,
that was my job.
Like we would set appointments,
we'd come in at noon and I have an
appointment with Ryder,
ABC,
you know,
we sit down and try to come up with
something.
Wow,
that's got to be weird when you first
worked with someone for the first time.
It's a lot of first dates.
It's a lot of first days,
but you know,
you find out pretty quickly how you can
just kind of a
particular.
When you're right with writers who do
that a lot,
uh,
you can very much walk into a room and
kind of throw all the,
you know,
oh,
how'd you do?
And all that kind of answers.
They get the,
you just get down to it and you'd just
be like,
dive into it and start working on
something to,
Hey,
this is on my mind,
but what do you think of this now?
That sucks,
you know,
and you have to be not nice a little bit
to each other and you have to.
And even if you don't know each other
well,
you have to act like you do in order to
get to a spot where a song can,
can be something.
And when do you ever write with no.
No,
no guitar,
no music.
Do you ever just have.
Absolutely.
There's a song that I wrote on the,
on the travel record that we had a
couple of records back traveler.
I wrote driving down the road,
you know,
driving through the desert on interstate
40,
you know,
wrote the whole thing driving and then I
had to go figure out how to play it.
Wow.
So as you're driving in your car,
did you record it?
And I had,
yeah,
I had a phone.
This is just turn the voice recorder on
the phone and trying to,
you know,
my wife was asleep in the seat next to
him and I'm trying not to wake my wife
up.
I'm being real quiet.
But yeah.
And then you get it done and you put it
away and you go listen to it later and
see what happens.
Wow.
So in all these years,
how many songs do you think you've
written an excess of a thousand?
Probably somewhere like that.
Do you have stacks of them?
Like laying around somewhere?
I mean,
they're all cataloged at the publishing
company I write for and they're all,
you know,
uh,
accounted for for the most part and I
can kind of go back through them and dig
in him if I need to.
Would you do that?
Like for an album?
Do you think this what I've been doing?
Yeah,
all the,
you know,
the,
this record we're putting out in the
last record that we have out a safe or a
few covers.
They're all songs that are,
you know,
a decade old or something.
Wow.
No kidding.
Yeah.
So might as well get stoned.
How long is that one?
Oh God,
that song is
a,
it's probably one of the first songs I
wrote when I moved to town,
so I was probably 25 when I wrote that.
So yeah,
it's 13 years old,
something like that too.
I love that song.
I love all your songs,
but I'm a big fan.
Thank you.
So when you are on tour and now I'm a,
are you bringing your own opening acts
with you,
you deciding who comes out with you?
Yeah,
well we,
we try to pick people that we know and
love and uh,
and we think,
you know,
fit or we would just want to support,
and uh,
you have a lot of great people out on
the road with CSI.
We have Brent cobb and Margo price and
uh,
Anderson the east and uh,
Marty Stewart just,
you know,
there's a lot of people that we love.
If you do,
have you listened to Ben and Brent
branch?
Nice.
Those.
Now I'm going to write this down
afterwards.
Yeah,
you gave me some suggestions.
you'll dig it.
It's,
it's good stuff.
Well,
birds of a feather flock together and I
know you type of dudes probably only
like other legit type of people,
so I'd probably get some good data.
Well I can't guess.
Yeah,
now my,
we,
we love,
we love music and we like,
we like to support.
There's something about the art form of
music that has always been very
inspirational to me and I've always
drawn upon it for.
I'm like,
you know that hunter s thompson quote
about music being fuel.
Ever seen that quote,
I'm not sure.
CV pull.
It's on my instagram page from pretty
recently.
Um,
when I was listening to Gary Clark Jr
just a couple of days ago.
Dude,
that guy can play.
Fuck
that guy.
That guy's a freak.
He was with honey honey.
Best Way.
Yeah.
And uh,
they did a version of midnight rider.
Yeah.
Here,
music has always been a matter of
energy.
To me,
a question of fuel.
Sentimental people call it inspiration,
but what they really mean is fuel.
I've always needed fuel.
I'm a serious consumer on some nights I
still believe that a car,
but the gas needle on empty can run
about 50 more miles if you have the
right music.
Very loud on the radio.
I liked it.
I liked music in the car myself.
That's it.
So it's,
it's uniquely inspirational.
Like very few things.
And the art of music and music creation
is such a,
um,
I think when it's done correctly,
I should say is a,
it's a very pure art form in the sense
that the people that are doing it are
really like digging into their creative
engines and you know,
just getting the gears turning and
pulling these things out and it
represents like however much burden you
have in your personality,
in your life and you're like,
that can either help you or hurt you in
this process.
And some people's music sort of
represents the torment of their life and
some people's music represents the
purity of their vision,
but it's all has different effects on
people and some sort of strange and
bizarre way.
Yeah.
I'd like to say that,
you know,
the songs I was talking about the
effort,
what else talking about this,
but I like songs that allow you to take
ownership of them and make them personal
to you.
Does that make sense?
And I like listening to,
and I think that's probably what we all
like about songs eventually is our
ability to relate to them,
but also they in and they become like a,
I come back and write a song I can play
a song on,
but it doesn't really mean anything
until somebody listens to it and then
they're uh,
you know,
perception of what that song is about in
relation to them comes back at us,
you know,
on a stage or it comes or lives in the
world that way.
And,
and that's so cool.
To me,
that's,
that's the,
that's the thing that makes a song
complete.
I don't feel like they're even done
until somebody listens to it and
attaches to it.
That's,
that's the thing that I love so much
about songs.
Yeah.
And everybody's thing is different too,
right?
It's like you could have two songs that
are the exact same song,
but there's sung by different people and
they have a completely different feeling
or some certain covers he listen to a
certain coverage just like,
Whoa,
just has it.
It just hits you in a totally different
way.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But,
and then the other side of that is,
you know,
two different people can listen to the
same version of a song and it means
totally different things to them because
they attached the pieces of their life
to it in a way that is unique to them.
And that's,
that's the coolest thing in world.
Yeah.
It's interactive in some sort of a weird
way,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And if it's not,
it's nothing exists.
What I mean by like sometimes people's
music represents sort of the tournament
is going on their own personal.
What I was thinking specifically,
I was amy winehouse,
like I was a big amy winehouse fan and
there's something about sash,
great.
Fucking phenomenal.
There's something about that Rehab Song
because she put that Rehab Song out when
everyone knew she was a mess right in.
And then she still tried to make me go
to rehab.
I said,
no,
you made it sound happening.
She's like,
fuck it.
I'm riding this thing right into the
beach.
Right.
I'm not stopping for the rocks.
I'm hitting the throttle.
You're gonna.
See where this goes.
It was tragic,
but it produced some,
some phenomenal music.
No doubt.
Yeah,
there was something to it.
There was like almost a fatalistic
acceptance of our own fate or something
like,
well,
and we can listen to it in that
perspective now that she's with us
anymore,
but you know,
at the time it was a lot of teenage
angst,
celebratory.
It felt celebratory of the time on the
other side of,
of,
of the tragedy of it.
It has a little more weight I think.
Yeah,
for sure.
But I mean,
man,
if you stop and think about how many
tortured souls put out unbelievable
music,
oh,
I think it's,
you know,
to some degree,
some of the greats,
you know,
it's almost like a requirement that they
are a little bit out there,
you know.
And so,
um,
which is,
it's a horrible thing for them,
but it's a beautiful thing for the rest
of us who get to listen to it.
Yeah,
right.
Man,
it's just the,
uh,
just to be an artist in any form,
right.
Requires all this vulnerability and just
trying to,
trying to find whatever it is when
you're trying to create something where,
where is that coming from?
The ether.
The Muse is trying to just find that
thing.
And then when you're dealing with your
own personal demons,
like especially the deep drug demons
seem to produce some of the most insane
music ever.
You know,
you think Hendrix and Kurt cobain.
Absolutely.
And You keep going down that list
forever.
Really?
Yeah.
And,
and I have,
I have a songwriter friend who is
convinced that you can't really produce
something that is really noteworthy
unless you have some kind of an
addiction issue.
So really?
Yeah.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I don't know if that's true,
but you know,
if you're saying that very thing,
you know,
like you look back at a history of rock
and roll and music in general,
you know,
there's a lot of heavy drugs and a lot
of,
uh,
you know,
getting out there on the edge.
Yeah.
Has in fact reduced some of the greatest
music that we've ever heard.
He also can hear it in the music,
like Stevie Ray Vaughan is a great
example.
He like here,
the getting out there on the edge in the
music.
Absolutely you.
You hear it with every ounce of
everything in it.
There's no safety net and that kind of
music.
This is just says all raw.
Yep,
absolutely.
You kinda crazy life,
man.
It's a crazy way to make a living.
It is a crazy.
Be Super Happy.
I don't have any of those issues.
I don't know,
but you don't have to have any of those
issues.
I don't think you have to have an
addiction issue to be great.
I just think you just have to pursue it.
Yeah.
You know what?
Maybe maybe the addiction.
I mean there's,
there can be healthy addictions.
I think that's true.
I think everybody would look at it.
Most people that I meet that are
successful in one way or another,
they have at the very least kind of
obsessive tendencies about something
bright and generally it's some part of
the work.
But uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
and focus.
I see a lot of focus,
like this kind of super focused thing
that when you,
when you see certain people,
you're like,
oh,
that's why he can do that,
because he or she can do that,
that they have this ability to focus.
Yeah.
There's A.
I've always been amazed too,
when someone can take an instrument and
make that instrument sound very specific
to them.
Like Gary Clark Jr is another good
example of that.
Like,
um,
see if you can find that video that I've
put up on my instagram way back when
with honey.
Honey,
honey,
honey and Gary Clark jr performed this
really tiny place in downtown la about
maybe a year ago and they did a midnight
set on like a Wednesday night or some
shit.
And uh,
Gary Clark is up there doing the almond
brothers midnight rider,
like,
listen to this and
do you know what I'm saying?
Like that
sound.
That's a perfect example.
What I'm talking about,
like that is him.
That is him.
But it's also everybody this beforehand,
that he's probably the one guy that we
have in modern times that really can
carry that torch for the blues and,
and,
you know,
all those great,
great guitar players that we don't have
a lot of them left,
you know,
like,
um,
and he,
he,
he can do that.
And,
and,
and that's a real kind of,
you know,
bb king approached,
just plans when real straight line
stuff.
But then he can,
he can do Hendrix and all you gotta be
crazy and psychedelic to,
he can do any of that.
And that's,
you know,
that guy shines.
And when you,
when you step on a stage with him,
you know,
it's uh,
we play,
we played,
he and I and Bonnie Raitt played a bb
king tribute on the grammy's few years
back.
And that was intimidating because,
you know,
Bonnie rates excellent in her own way,
like she has,
she has that thing just like he has
where it's just like those,
those people are there special people.
Yeah.
I agree.
And there's something about them that,
like what hunter was saying,
that their fuel,
like I saw that and I ran home and I
wrote,
I wrote for like three hours.
Yeah.
So it just was pumped up.
I just,
I just felt like I'd seen something,
you know,
like I just,
I touched some new dimension.
You listened to a lot of Freddie King.
You're listening to Freddie King?
No.
Oh no man.
You right.
This time I'm gonna start writing down.
You got to get on Freddie King.
Freddy King.
What,
what kind of Shit is he?
He's blues.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's,
he's not with us anymore.
But Oh,
uh,
you know,
there's bb King Albert King and Freddie
King.
And I never heard of Freddy.
Oh,
well you've probably ever seen that
show,
uh,
eastbound and down.
You know,
the same theme song at the front of
that.
Yeah,
that's right.
Oh,
okay.
But then I love Freddy King.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a wealth of,
of fuel if you want some,
uh,
and Freddie King,
that's,
that's a pretty,
a standard staple of,
of listening for me.
If I go,
if I want to turn something on and,
but it made me feel right,
Freddie,
Freddie King,
I got to John Lee Hooker problem.
When I start thinking about blues,
I just listened to Johnny Hooker.
I've so much.
John Lee Hooker on my phone.
I have no room for other people.
Now you gotTa,
you gotta get you gotta get Freddy King
and Freddie King in there.
But when I,
when I'm tired,
I don't feel like working out.
I put boom,
boom,
boom on and woo.
Here we go.
We're off to the races.
It's just something about those types of
songs,
you know,
that deep blues.
It's just got this extra special soul to
it,
you know,
there's just a,
you're in sort of immersed in the
feeling of those people,
you know,
it's uh,
it's heavy duty stuff,
man.
Music is heavy duty stuff,
Um,
how fortunate do you feel?
Uh,
I'm the luckiest man in the world.
I say that all the time.
And it's true.
I am absolutely the luckiest dude in the
world.
I would imagine you feel that way.
Yeah.
I mean,
you found that it's actually true.
I think I'm the luckiest guy in the
world,
but I'll let you slide.
Well,
I'm top five,
top five.
I think we're all the luckiest person in
the world.
If you're actually found your thing that
you like to do and you don't really,
you work,
but you don't really work.
Work well.
Yeah.
I mean,
listen,
I do a lot.
We do a lot.
We've got to work.
It's work in the sense of it's time
consuming.
Yes.
It requires effort and focus,
but I.
Yes.
But listen,
there's nothing else I would rather do
for a living and I'm grateful and
thankful everyday for it because I love
it when you could tell.
I mean,
it really comes out in your music,
really tell it's pure.
Do you,
uh,
do you listen to any classical,
the classical music?
Yeah.
I,
you know,
when I was a kid I used to listen to
more classical music than I do now,
but you know,
I enjoy occasionally going to the
symphony,
you know,
but I haven't gone in years,
but I,
I,
I do like that music it,
it moves me in a different kind of way
than listening to different gang would.
But all right,
here's the big question.
Jazz jazz.
I do like jazz music,
not necessarily like super experimental
jazz music that gets way,
way out there like acid jazz,
like Coltrane,
like just.
Yeah.
And once again,
I am not a uh,
in no way am I an authority on jazz,
but if it's on I'm,
I will enjoy it because I enjoy as a
musician.
I enjoyed just like I hear enjoy great
blues players.
There's so many great musicians and
jazz,
like I had an opportunity to rush songs.
Damn Wilson
called me up one time to go write some
songs for the preservation hall jazz
band.
And so we wrote some songs.
I knew nothing about New Orleans jazz,
what's,
what,
uh,
whatsoever.
And,
but I went down to New Orleans and I
participated in this and wrote these
songs that now live in the jazz world so
that,
that really is thrilling to me to get to
that thing I was telling you about where
I get,
go hop into somebody else's space and
see if I'm helpful,
you know,
that's,
that's cool to me.
You know,
so now I have,
you know,
I have that it feels like to me like
that's a feather in my cap.
I got to go participate with those guys.
And they're so great.
Every one of them.
I have some friends that love that sort
of collaboration thing too,
whether it's in music or I have a good
buddy of mine who writes a lot for my
friend.
Tony Hinchcliffe writes a lot for people
for uh,
for roasts and he does punch up on shows
and things along those lines.
But he relishes that opportunity.
He likes collaborating,
likes helping people out on stuff.
Yeah.
Well this gives you the opportunity to
flush your mind in a way that maybe you
wouldn't.
Yeah.
In your own space,
you know,
what do you do when you're not doing
music?
That's all I do pretty much really,
that I play music and I'm uh,
you know,
I,
I like to,
I have things I like to do.
I like,
you know,
I like to fish,
but I don't get to do that a whole lot.
Bass fish.
What do you do?
I grew up in a trout stream.
Oh yeah.
I'm not a philosopher in Kentucky,
but not a fly fisherman,
but a spinning tackle.
Yeah.
Just spend a tackle.
I used to use a little ultra lot.
Spending my summers were spent as a kid.
I'd be in being the creek at 5:30,
you know,
my friend Steve Renaud was just talking
to a famous writer recently and his last
podcast,
I don't remember the man's name,
but he's famous in the fishing writing
world and he's a fly fisherman and he's
like,
he had a really interesting question.
He said,
why is so much great,
great literature attached to fly fishing
but not to spin tackle.
It's true.
That's a good question.
And I,
I think,
uh,
that's the,
I dunno,
it's Kinda like using spend tackles like
this a workman.
It's,
it's,
it's like a blue collar way of doing it
or that's my perception of it.
And then people who were fly fishermen
and I've seen these guys in action,
you know,
use a fly Rod.
It,
there's an art to it,
but there's an art,
there's an art to using the all,
all of it.
But the gas,
we were fly fishermen and take a lot
more pride in the art of it.
Yeah.
And the,
and the,
and this.
And please forgive me,
fishermen out there if I'm,
if I'm misrepresenting it,
anybody who likes to do either of these
things,
but my perception of it is a
gas with a spinning reel.
And then me,
I just want to catch the fish.
I'm not,
if it means I'm flipping it out there,
if it means I'm tossing it,
if it means I'm jake fishing with it
doesn't matter.
I figuring
out the way to catch the fish.
The fly fishermen,
they liked the process.
Yeah.
I started out with a,
a spinning Rod.
Um,
I actually started out with Zeb,
Co push buttons,
Spin Caster Jammies,
and then uh,
then I went to bait casting reel and
then for bass,
and then when I into trout fishing I
eventually moved on to fly fishing and I
learned how to tie some flies.
And let's say you're serious about it.
So I'm sitting here talking about your.
No,
that's your hobby.
It's been a long time now when I fish I
fish maybe once a year,
like on vacation.
That's especially when it happens for me
is I,
you know,
charter,
a guy on a boat somewhere to go easy.
It's fun.
Yeah.
I've done it in Hawaii,
in Mexico.
And the great thing is like say if you
stay at a resort that either like you
could run a boat,
they'll take you out,
you catch a tune or something like that,
and then you cook it and eat it for
lunch and it's amazing.
That's great.
Yeah.
That's about the extent that my fishing
these days,
my other outdoor activities are sort of
overwhelmed my fishing time,
but there's something about the people
that get into fly fishing that it's not
just fishing with.
One of the weird things about fly
fishing is a lot of them let the fish
go.
There's a lot of catch and release going
on with fly fishing,
which I mean I'm.
I liked that too.
I mean I used to let a lot of them go.
I get that,
but I'm a little.
I'm a little tormented on that.
You're putting a fucking hook through
someone's head and you're going to let
it go.
Like how about just not doing that?
If you really love the fish,
how about just fish with no hook at all
when they bite it,
you know,
you would have had them.
That's probably fair.
Yeah.
It's probably the way to go.
It's weird that we would be.
It's this weird thing that we have in
our head.
We were trying to activate those reward
systems that were there in place in
order to keep ourselves fed.
Right?
Like if there's a thing that happens
when you catch a fish you've seen like
I've seen with my little kids have taken
my,
my daughters fishing and when they catch
a fish they have this look in their face
like,
oh,
I got it,
I got it.
Oh,
like this is a super exciting.
When they pull it out of the boat and
then the fact that they're going to get
to eat it later.
There's some weird primal DNA thing that
gets activated when you catch something
and I think that's what these fly
fishermen that are letting the fish go
or trying to do that.
Just little junkies for that.
That,
that feeling,
that DNA activation,
that reward system thing and obviously
it's difficult and obviously there's a
lot of tremendous amount of skill and
finesse involved and fly casting role
casting,
trying to place this fly right in this
little pool and dragon with the current
and get that nasty trout to bite onto
it.
But you also want to own it.
You want to have him and let him go.
Like you don't want to like say I
could've had you,
but there's no hook on dark side of
fluff.
You want to know you got it.
You don't want to know he bit.
So no one goes fly fishing with no hook.
They go with a barbless hook and they'll
catch it and then they'll let it go and
that's,
that's fine.
As a barbless hook like,
okay.
How about I put a Barbara so through
your fucking face.
Good.
That's not good.
You're trying to ruin fishermen.
Are fishing for all catch and release
fishermen?
I am not in.
I,
I supported 100 percent and I've done
it.
I'm a hypocrite.
That regard.
I have done some catch and release,
but I feel like there is a weirdness to
it that it's this why you're not eating
it.
Like why?
Like how about you can't just look at
them.
No,
you got to catch him,
catch him in and then let them go.
But how,
how are you going to look at them if you
don't care?
I'll get him in the water.
Here's the thing.
A good percentage,
I don't know what the number is,
especially when you're like salmon
fishing and you're using like heavy
tackle,
a good percentage of your catch and
release and have those fish are never
gonna.
Make it catch them with a big lure.
Barb hooks get them deep in the throat.
He pulled them out.
Their gills are bleeding.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's a scenario that you don't like.
Yeah,
catch in that essence.
Most fishermen I think would know that
you can't turn that fish back loose,
but you have to.
Sometimes you have to,
but you have to turn them loose because
it's the law as the regulations and you
turn it loose and you watch it swim away
and look because going about a 40
percent chance.
Yeah.
No,
and everybody hates that.
Yeah,
that worst,
but,
but they still want that feeling.
I,
that's a weird to catching the fish
things.
A weird feeling.
Apparently it's that way with a
butterfly.
Catchers too,
because human beings used to be
insectivores.
Really?
Yeah.
I was listening to this lecture wants by
Terence Mckenna and he was talking about
that.
Terence Mckenna,
great psychedelic author and lecturer.
He was talking about how he was really
into butterfly catching at one point in
time and the odd thing is that it
activates this very primal reward system
in your body the same way catching a
fish would that.
It's because human beings used to be
insectivores.
We used to eat a lot of insects,
so when you do find some rare butterfly
that you've been after for months and
months and you have the opportunity to
drop the net on that mother fucker
get too excited about them.
That's a weird sort of trophy hunting
butterfly hunting too,
because you're allowed to do that.
You can take that little fucker,
dry them out and put them on a wall
somewhere and nobody thinks you're a
barbarian.
Like people are real racist when it
comes to what animals are allowed to be
dead.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Pigs and cows are screwed.
Pigs and cows.
The Bulls.
I mean,
but more so bugs,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Nobody likes blogs.
I went to an ashram once and this lady
who was running the Armstrong had a.
can of raid and she was talking to me
about the ant problem that they have and
I was like,
hold up,
so you spray,
you spray these ants with poison?
And she's like,
yeah,
and I go see,
kill the ants.
I go,
isn't that contrary to what you're
teaching?
She's like,
sometimes there's just things you have
to do because otherwise the ants will
get in our food and
like,
Huh,
this is odd.
A urine,
an odd crossroads here,
lady.
You're a Buddhist,
living in an ashram with a can of poison
that you use for living beings that you
don't like being around you.
I have nothing.
I don't know,
but if she was like,
if she had like cats that she was
killing with a baseball bat,
everybody would be mad.
She'd be in jail.
Yeah.
Weird,
right?
Yeah.
With weird rules.
Sorry to take you down this world.
This is very interesting to me.
I didn't know that human beings used to
be insectivores,
so yeah.
Apparently something new everyday.
Well,
that's one of the things that they talk
about in terms of the future of protein,
that insects provide very complex,
complete proteins and they can provide
it to large amounts of people fairly
inexpensively.
And so,
um,
cricket proteins,
very popular tail if you know this,
know a lot of people eat cricket
protein.
Yeah.
They have cricket bars and shit.
Cricket bars.
Yeah.
They make bars at a crickets and cricket
protein bars and apparently they taste
pretty good.
Well,
you know,
my daughter ate,
uh,
you know,
we bought like on vacation somewhere,
like there's novelty sack of like
barbecue crickets or something because
kids wanted to try him.
Of course.
My mom was like,
after he actually got it out of the
package,
he was like,
ah,
I don't know about that.
But I was like,
I'll try it.
And she ate it and then she was like,
it's pretty good.
They're not bad.
What is it as a cricket milkshake?
Hey.
Yeah.
Is that,
is that pre made?
There's the cricket bars from the
powder.
I think it would look more palatable if
they didn't have a picture of a cricket,
like crawling out of it.
Hide that shit.
So there's the.
There's the cricket protein powder.
That's crap.
They cooked the cricket grind,
those little fuckers up and turn it into
protein powder and it's apparently has a
complete amino acid profile.
It's easy to digest and it doesn't make
people feel bad.
Like,
look at that.
Look at the grams of protein per 100
gallons of water.
How much you can get for a cow.
You only get six grams of protein per
100 grams of water or 100 gallons of
water,
but for crickets you get 71 grams of
protein for the same amount of water.
Wow.
So it's more than 10 times the amount of
protein.
So you could.
And I don't think it has near the impact
on the environment.
I'm in terms of like raising them.
They don't have a lot of the waste
products and the issues that cows have.
Methane
smells.
This is a.
This was amazing.
Sorry Dude.
It's all good.
I,
I'm sitting here thinking about eating
crickets.
I'm thinking about switching.
I've had crickets before,
man.
I was in Mexico and they cooked them and
left him in the room,
like in the.
We stayed at a hotel and there's a
little snack,
like a little snack thing.
It was a little.
They were like a almost like a soy sauce
based or some sort of assault based
chips or something.
Yeah,
and they were,
they were fried and you just crunch them
and I was like,
okay,
these are actually pretty good.
I like this.
They're essentially related,
but a lot of bugs are related to
shellfish.
Whereas like we found on fear factor
that if you're allergic to shrimp,
you're also allergic to roaches.
Really?
Yeah.
We found that out because we made a duty
roaches and he is.
When he started having an allergic
reaction,
we had to get them a shot of adrenaline
and taken to the hospital.
That's awful.
Yeah,
it was a bad day.
Yeah.
He,
you know,
I guess your throat closes up on you and
you start,
you know,
a lot of inflammation.
You start wheeze and yeah,
it was not fun.
Yeah.
But crickets.
Good and high in protein you ever,
you never eat anything weird to you?
Like a straight laced eater?
I'm pretty,
yeah,
I'm pretty straight wild game.
Uh,
my dad was a bird hunter and a rabbit
hunter growing up,
but I've never,
I've never loved it.
No,
no.
It's all about how it's cooked really,
right?
Yeah.
And I don't know if we ever got that
down in my house.
So yeah,
it's,
it's tricky.
Like I think if you're around a real
wild game chef,
like there's a guy named Hank Shaw who's
been on this podcast before who is a
hunter who is also like a real
extraordinary chef and he makes these
amazing dishes with wild game and he's
one of those guys is like,
you know,
you think it's bad because you haven't
cooked it.
Right.
Let me cook it.
Yeah,
I think there's a lost art to some of it
or a lesser known art maybe.
Where are you living right now?
Man?
I live south of Nashville,
Tennessee.
So when you flew into hell today and you
see like literally it's on fire for
people listening at this point in time.
This is one of the worst fires in the
history of Los Angeles.
Pretty scary.
Yeah,
because it's what's called a dry
hurricane.
Meaning there,
there's hurricane force winds,
but there's no rain and the fires are
going fucking crazy.
Fifty thousand acres down in a day is
nothing right now.
It's a while.
We've been here a few days and we were,
uh,
we got in two,
three days ago and we've been doing some
other things,
tv things and whatever.
But looking up that on the news is not
a,
not a fun thing to watch.
And I'm,
I'm so heartbroken for everybody losing
their homes.
And uh,
it's,
it's pretty tragic.
Awful thing to have to watch.
Yeah,
it certainly is.
It's the side effect of living in a
place that doesn't have any weather.
No,
there you go.
Everything dries out.
It's so rarely rains here.
You know,
it's.
And when you get like these crazy winds,
the Santa Ana winds that happened every
year.
It's just,
this is extraordinary.
The winds here and just perfect time for
fires obviously.
So if somebody kicking these things up
or what's,
what's the deal?
Really no one knows when that could be.
Arson could be.
Feels like that could be.
Look,
there's some sick fucks out there.
They know that the wind is a bad thing
for fire and then all of a sudden the
fire shows up.
It's entirely possible that have 20
million people.
There's one or two people that are
either fucking mind.
Yeah.
That's way out there.
Is that what you were thinking?
I don't know.
I just watched it.
I'm just like.
I mean the fire spontaneously start,
you know that.
Yeah.
And these.
I don't know.
It just seems.
Well,
you're probably right.
I mean that's one of the suspicions is
that it's arson,
unrelated or this several fires,
one of them and there's so many you
don't want at this point.
I'm just like somebody running around,
like thinking I don't know what the
monitor they happen simultaneously.
Yeah.
All during the same crazy conditions and
they happen like way far apart from each
other.
So you talked to firefighters about it
and they're like,
there's a lot of times we don't know,
but there's a lot of times there's some
serious suspicions.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just,
it's unfortunately,
you'd have to think about that.
I mean think about all these human
beings and there's one or two or
however,
whatever the number is there,
so tortured and so in,
in pain and so fucked up there.
Their wires crossed.
Yeah.
I don't get it.
I don't get it and I hope that's not the
case,
but I,
but I'll watch all these guys on the
news,
you know,
up on the roofs trying to save their
property or a firefighter's putting
themselves in harm's way or guys flying
helicopters,
Dublin water in zero visibility
conditions in is just like,
man,
it's just,
it's awful.
It is awful.
You know,
it's the round this time of year.
You really appreciate firefighters.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And I think a lot of people take them
for granted most of the time until you
need them.
They're like,
there are superheroes that only get
credit when they do some shit.
Right.
You know,
and when they do do some shit,
you realize like,
oh well without them,
like I talked to a firefighter wants,
it freaked me the fuck he was saying.
It's just a matter of time until one day
with the right winds,
there's a fire that burns all the way to
the ocean,
just goes right through La and there's
nothing we can do about it.
And I was like,
what?
And he's like,
it's a matter of time.
He goes,
everybody thinks it.
It's just a matter of catching the right
fire and then you realize today like,
oh,
he's right.
Like,
oh yeah,
Bel airs on fire where all the rich
people that's on fire.
Yeah,
no,
it's a,
like I said,
it's like live on the news.
We were watching it in the hotel room,
you know,
it's just
pretty hardcore.
Yeah,
I mean we changed our route to get over
here today just to get it because
there's road closures and reflect that.
Did it take you more time?
I think we gave ourselves like an hour
and hour and 20 minutes.
Hour and a half to get up the day.
So what else you got going on right now?
Uh,
um,
was we did a few TV things and we're
kind of winding down for the year and
then we'll kick back up in,
uh,
January to get the grammys and January I
guess,
um,
and then kind of slowly get back into
it,
but my wife's pregnant with twins so
we're trying to graduation.
Thank you.
Uh,
you know,
have,
and she toured with instincts with me
pretty much all the time and so we're
trying to figure out the new reality of
that.
You know,
we have two kids out with us,
but now we're going to four.
So it's how old are your kids?
They're eight and seven.
So do you bring a tutor on the road with
you?
How do you do that?
My mother in law is a retired second
grade school teachers.
Convenient.
Yeah.
So,
so we homeschool our children on the
road and they,
but they get,
when they studied the Boston tea party,
they get to go look at all the stuff in
Boston,
you know,
it's a,
it's a different kind of education.
But are there things like that kind of
live and breathe for them a little bit
more than than what I got grown up and
hopefully someday they'll appreciate
that.
Oh,
I'm sure they will.
I mean it's got to be interesting to
them to,
to see their dad go from being a singer
songwriter to all of a sudden being a
celebrity center of.
They realized that,
I don't know,
I think to them they're,
they're young enough and you know,
that just seems like,
oh,
that yeah.
Mom and dad have to go sing a show.
You know what they did?
What are your mom and dad going to go
sit in?
My mom makes houses.
She doesn't say yeah they don't,
they don't have real uh,
what's,
what's the,
they don't have anything else to compare
it to reference point of reference was
looking for.
So it's just Kinda,
that's just kinda what life is to them.
When you tour,
how long do you go?
Like how much of a stretch?
Well,
we very rarely try to.
I mean,
we've tried to be wicked warriors as
much as we can and do,
you know,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
Ron's.
But,
you know,
some things logistically that doesn't
make any sense if you're gonna run
across Canada or we're,
we're based in Nashville.
So if we want to run the west coast,
we're out here for a couple of weeks or
something like that,
but never longer than that,
you know,
we never trust it out.
We're not very rock and roll about it
and we don't live out there and don't
want to,
you know.
So um,
I love to play shows.
There's a limit on how many I could sing
and in a week it's three's the limit.
So we stick with that and try to make
that a habit,
has as much kind of home time.
And uh,
so all the guys in the band,
the crew and you know,
everybody's got kids and families and
things and it's a hard,
it's a hard way to make a living if
you're always gone.
Like,
yeah,
like months and months and months gone.
What's,
that's a lot.
That's,
that's the rock and roll way of doing
things a lot.
Yeah,
I know sturgill how to do that.
Like that for awhile.
He didn't have to.
He chose to.
Chose to.
Yeah,
I convinced I had to convince him to
that,
but he had to convince him of that,
that he didn't have to.
Yeah.
I don't know.
He only,
he convinces himself if anything,
I'm not gonna say that I know what
you're saying,
but you've influenced him.
I'm not,
I'm not even going to say I influenced
it,
but I would tell suggested I would tell
him,
hey man,
you don't have to.
Why are you doing this?
So he felt like what?
I think all his years of work in regular
jobs,
you know,
working on the railroad and do all the
shit that he had to do when success
came,
he was like,
Jesus Christ,
I've got to keep this fire going well
and get the kindle a kindle and you
know,
absolutely you had this moment,
you know,
when you have a little something going
on with your life.
Well I got to,
you know,
make hay while the sun shines on and
understand that wholeheartedly.
But,
you know,
we're all human beings and we all have
limits.
Yeah.
Do you have a limit of the amount of
days that you could sing in a week?
Yeah.
Three.
That's it.
And then your voice starts to get
strained.
Yeah.
That's,
I mean,
that's,
I think pretty hard too,
you know?
So,
um,
yeah,
that's,
that's the end.
You know,
and I,
and I have conversations with other
singers when I run into it was like,
how many shows can you play in a week?
And you know,
some guys it's too.
And some day,
some guys it's like I can play everyday
of the week.
Wow.
And that,
but that's not me through free shows,
just kind of,
do you ever have a greedy,
make moneybags agent?
It's like,
listen Chris four shows a week,
25 percent more money.
Well
just one more show.
I wouldn't call anybody out work with
greedy,
make moneybags and Christopher two shows
a night out,
a big deal.
But certainly certainly,
you know,
certainly everybody,
everybody wants a,
you know,
as you work with.
And that's their job is to try to
maximize what you're able to do
momentarily.
And,
and you know,
sometimes you have to look at me,
go,
sorry I can't do this physically.
Not yet.
Not physically possible.
And then they have to deal within those
parameters and we figured out how to
maximize that.
Does every country music singer have to
live around Nashville?
Is that like requisite?
Um,
I don't,
it seems like it's a giant collection of
you fuckers is one spot that is the kind
of the hub for a actress living in La or
New York,
whatever,
wherever the.
I think it's La,
if you,
if you wanna if you want to be in a
certain industry,
it helps,
must win,
must be present to win,
you know,
uh,
to some degree,
you know,
um,
do you feel that that place has a
certain energy to it as well though?
It does have an energy to it and then
has had an interview to it and it's a
very changing energy at the moment.
Um,
I don't,
I don't live in Nashville proper
anymore,
but I did for years.
Um,
but it's uh,
it's a different place,
you know,
and it's not just a music place,
but there's so much else going on.
It was 19 or 20 cranes building condos
downtown,
you know,
what's going on in Nashville.
It just,
I don't know,
there's A.
Everybody wants to buy a condo.
I guess
I don't understand it,
but yeah,
it's,
there's an influx of people who all of a
sudden think it's a good idea to move to
Nashville.
Well,
that's what I had heard.
I'd heard that.
It's a,
it's almost becoming like La [inaudible]
a little bit.
I don't know what that means,
but if,
if that,
if that means that there's a lot of
condo buildings,
chicks with lips like this,
man,
I really don't.
Honestly,
I don't.
I don't run around and I go into
Nashville when I have to go into
Nashville for certain supplies for
supplies,
and then I parked myself in the,
out in the country.
So that's where you live.
Live.
That's nice.
Kind of spread.
Yeah.
We have a little bit of land and
wildlife animals.
Oh yeah.
None of those.
Bobcat's and Turkeys and.
Oh,
that's nice,
dear.
You name it.
Yeah.
The one I've heard about Nashville is
that Nashville started out as sort of
this pure sort of music environment and
then over time it became a money grab
and people realized that it's a,
um,
a music environment and they said,
how do we capitalize on this?
And then people said,
oh,
I heard this is a music environment.
I'm gonna move there.
And then it became like a
place to be,
to be seen and that it's,
it's still got the music there,
but it's also like weirdly compromised.
Does that make sense?
Uh,
no more than anywhere else.
I mean,
I said human nature,
man.
I don't know.
I don't want to say
it sounds very like I'm anti,
you know,
any,
any corporate involvement,
have anything to
say that it's been
okay.
Tainted or it's all a money grab or
something.
I don't think it's all.
I know.
I'm definitely not saying that.
I love Nashville by the way.
Okay.
Well No,
I,
I do too,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
the,
the relate opinion of.
Or was that your opinion?
No,
no,
it's other people that I know,
people that have lived there and then
moved back.
Got You.
Yeah.
I just,
people that had this romantic notion of
I want to go there and this is like sort
of countryish city where everybody's
soulful.
They're all singing songs and it's just,
he'd go down and see all these amateur
van or these bands are just starting out
and they're amazing.
Yeah.
I don't think that that's really,
uh,
that that's some kind of mayberry
version of,
of,
of what Nashville is.
I mean,
that's Narnia.
Yeah,
that's,
that's that.
I think that's some kind of Unicorn that
you're inventing in your mind.
If you think that that's any challenge
you're going to you like that.
There's like A.
I don't know,
I don't know what the equivalent would
be,
but feeling like you moved to some
island somewhere and everybody walks
around and has yachts and you know,
just just direct Martinez all day or
whatever.
You know,
it was just like,
that's not even true.
Well,
this like places that you're supposed to
go to.
Like when I was in Boston,
when I first started out doing standup,
I had heard about the comedy store.
That was like the Mecca rocky had to get
to the comedy store in Hollywood and I
was like spoken with harsh tones and
everybody sort of came to that place.
It's like a drew everybody in from
across the country and from my friends
like honey,
honey and other people that I know that
lived in Nashville for awhile.
That was Nashville was kind of that.
To them it's like what it was is like
this kind of place where you'd seen and
heard so much amazing music has come out
of that part of the world and it's so
music centered,
you know?
I mean,
it just,
it has a different vibe because it's a
very art.
It's a very artistic city.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
But,
but there's,
there's also,
there's a side to it now and it's been
the last five,
sorry,
Nashville,
if it feels like I'm talking about you,
but it's a,
there's a thing now where you go
downtown and it's more like you're going
to a giant Bachelorette party or
something,
you know,
it was just like every,
every bodies,
I don't know,
just looking to get,
drink their face and,
and listened to bad cover.
So what I'm saying like I'm sorry,
I need to apologize for,
okay,
you're being honest,
but it's,
you know,
and it's great for the city and a lot of
ways a tourism wise and monetarily and
all those.
But it also changes that uh,
whatever,
some notions of that romantic thing that
you're talking about,
those things still exist,
but they're there.
They have to be like a lot of things
that have sold.
They need to be sought out.
Right?
Like the difference between a real old
school bbq joint and Tgi Friday's.
I have nothing as Tgi Fridays,
but you know what you mean?
I know what you mean to.
I see.
You're laughing at me like back peddling
all the.
No,
no,
no.
Forced the end of this.
I didn't mean to.
I just,
we're just,
I'm just talking about,
but my point about all of it really is
the idea of artistic integrity is a
fleeting thing in,
in,
in a sacred thing and a critical thing
for a guy like you to create the kind of
music that you make and I'm always
interested like how someone cultivates
that,
how someone protects that.
Because I think it's,
it's what goes away.
It's when,
when things go off the rails,
it's usually the focus away from the
creative aspect of it going the art to
making the thing that you loved in the
beginning when you got into this thing,
you know,
and sometimes people get.
It happens.
Comedians in a big way,
they good movies and they become famous
and then they believe their own bullshit
and they put out these specials that are
terrible.
It's,
it's real easy to fall into.
Sure.
And Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
but there's also,
there's a,
there's a side of that I would,
I would argue that maybe that is what's
in their heart at that moment and that's
just as real as anything else,
you know,
but
I would argue that it's there in the
wrong environment.
Well has been surrounded by the wrong
people with the wrong influences and the
wrong.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll go with that.
But everybody's going to evolve in one
way or another.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and everybody's going to have these high
points and low points of,
of,
of where they really were in the zone,
so to speak or not in the zone.
Yeah.
Creatively,
I think that that is just life and um,
but I,
you know,
I dunno as long for me if there's a way
to try to preserve some notion of
integrity.
It's just that thing I sent earlier.
It's just like if you let all the other
stuff just put the blinders on and go,
alright,
here I am here,
here are the guys that I played music
with and then the girls were going to
sit in a room,
what are we going to do,
what will we do if none of this other
stuff existed and that's.
And that's,
that's the way you keep it,
which should be as you keep it right in
the moment and right into the room and
don't let some of some notion of trying
to outdo yourself for a out sell
yourself or you know,
make more money than the other guy or,
or having number one over top of the
other guy or you know,
because all that kind of stuff's
manufacturer two number ones and those
are just numbers that.
And some of them are so a tainted by
people just doing things that,
that manufacturer,
that number that they want to have that
it doesn't,
it's not even a real thing at that
point.
I don't know why.
I always felt weird about contests and
things that in any sort of like ranking
system that involves art.
Okay,
so your way anti,
any kind of.
Well,
I just think that like the Oscars and
the grammys and all that kind of shit
like that.
Like I don't give a fuck who you think
is great.
I don't think.
I don't care who you think is the
greatest number one,
like the number.
Here's the end.
The winter is open the envelope.
Oh my God.
Is he going to get it?
Like the work is the work,
the work is done.
Like it's.
If it's apocalypse now is a great
fucking movie.
It doesn't matter what you give them a
gold statue or not like what's the work?
The work is great.
Like for it to win a thing or not when a
thing,
you know in some of the things that have
one,
you can tell that the wind is tainted by
the political climate that the people
are like leaning towards something
that's socially aware and console.
Somebody made a movie with lesbians and
Save the planet from.
You know what I mean?
It's like that kind of shit becomes
transparent and obvious and you can do
that in rig the system and win an award.
I think that awards for art or goofy
awards for comedy or super every comedy
competition I've ever seen.
They're super goofy.
It's just,
it's missing the whole idea of the
thing,
the whole idea.
The thing is supposed to be the art.
It's not supposed to be trying to win an
award.
No,
it's not and,
but you know,
if you want an award out of that and it
allows you to make more art and it makes
people pay attention to the art.
So it's sort of a bastardization.
It's always felt like there was a show
called last comic standing and the good
thing about it was it,
it got a lot of comics that people
hadn't heard of and they put them on
television,
the career,
but the bad thing was that they're doing
like a contest and like who's the
audience platform or do you want Mike?
Hey,
what about debbie?
That's fucking weird.
It's weird.
Okay.
We have a lot of those shows.
Yes,
there's not as many anymore.
A lot of from the singing,
right.
That's what I'm saying.
People like to watch those shows because
people also like the idea that you can
be one thing,
one minute and one moment on television
can make you some other totally
different person below them on that.
Like that's why Susan Boyle was so
famous,
right?
Yes.
We saw this woman.
Everybody was doubting her.
She goes out there and she's got pipes
and she belts that song out and you can
see Simon who's just a douche bag
because was like,
Holy Shit.
She's amazing.
Like you could see it like undeniable.
But those were good moments though.
Those are good moments.
Those are the best moments.
The other good moments are like when
they have American idol,
they have those people that have no
business being there and they played
their auditions too.
Those are the other good moments for the
wrong reasons,
right?
Yes.
But you know,
and if you're watching that show that
you're watching it for that too.
Right.
Is there a good show to introduce people
to country music?
Like,
you know,
they used to have.
There used to be like shows where people
could,
you know,
yeah,
we used to have,
you know,
like Nashville now and tell you like,
I don't think that really exists
anymore.
Like A,
like a country music was specific show.
No,
I don't think we really have that
anymore.
Like a variety show,
like Johnny Cash show or a show or
something like that.
No,
we don't have that anymore and I don't
know how much people want that anymore,
you know,
otherwise it might exist but one person
to do it,
you know,
maybe maybe there's not the right person
to do it.
I don't know.
I just think someone needs to make it.
I feel like there's so much what you're
telling me about all these artists I got
to go look into and I'm sure there's a
bunch that are coming up that are
probably equally talented and you know,
maybe they just need an opportunity like
that.
Like something like along those lines,
some sort of a show,
a variety show.
Our really talented people can come and
show their songs,
but it'd be good.
I,
you know,
my,
well,
the closest thing to that right now,
have you seen this Mike Judge show the
Mike Judge,
the guy from King of the hill and uh,
it's Beavis and butthead tales from the
tour bus or something like that.
What is that?
He takes,
he talks to all these old school like
Texas country acts or,
or like it's all these,
all the folklore of country music and
these and he doesn't like interview
style and they're all telling me stories
and latest trailer.
Oh Man.
Mike judge.
Yeah.
He'll
be at 36 brand new cars.
The horn sound like a dying.
Wow.
Jerry machine gun.
Shot up a demo right next door.
$50,000 with false teeth.
I knew that he was facing his shoes and
I didn't want me in the lab.
So they would tell stories and then they
animate them.
Yeah.
Well this is what all these guys that
you see are animated.
These are the real guys that lived a lot
of these things.
Telling these stories.
This is,
these are not made up characters or in
any,
in any way.
And,
and I know some of the guys that wind up
being animated on these things and,
and I have for years said,
you know,
if even half of the folk lore that
exists in country music could be told,
uh,
it would be the,
it would be the biggest thing in the
world,
you know,
and that's what he's doing right now
with that show and he's doing an
excellent job of it and it's really for
me,
and maybe it's not as entertaining to
other people,
I don't know,
but for me as a musician,
no one,
some of the folk lore and knowing how
many great characters and storytellers
exists in country music and have
existed.
Um,
it's so refreshing to see these guys get
stories told about him.
That's awesome.
I didn't even know Mike Judge's a
country music fan.
I didn't either,
but I got to tell you,
he's knocking it out of the park as far
as I'm concerned with this,
with this,
with this TV show.
I hope it does really well.
I'm so glad you brought this up.
Yeah,
it looks hilarious.
It's,
it's awesome.
And I don't say that about much,
I don't really like get super pumped up
about a lot.
Do you watch other shit?
Yeah.
You know,
I like a lot of um,
I like,
I mean some pretty obvious things like
game of thrones and walking dead.
I'm ended that.
I like,
I like kind of science fiction based
things and uh,
you know,
I liked but I liked,
I like things that are done well,
whatever it is.
And I think both of those were done well
to do you binge watch TV shows?
Absolutely.
That's the only way I can watch the TV
show,
you know,
because half the time I'm doing
something when,
when it actually comes on,
you know?
Right,
right.
So when you look at yourself right now
and you look at all this cool shit that
you're doing,
do you hope that just keep doing it this
way?
Do you have some grand plans?
We,
we far surpassed any grand plan that I
might've had collected years ago.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm hopeful that we get to continue to
do some cool things and have fun doing
it.
And I'm,
you know,
I'm,
I'm at that age where,
you know,
I'm just old enough not to be stupid
with what we're doing and
hopefully young enough to really get to
keep doing it for a little while and,
and I,
you know,
I don't know,
man,
I,
I'm grateful for anything that we've
gotten to do and we'll get to do in the
future and hopefully the next few years
will just be a continuation of that.
That's all you could ask for Matt.
I mean,
if you're,
what what you're doing now is so awesome
and so much fun.
Yeah,
I can't,
I can't imagine if I,
if I could like write a script for how,
you know,
this is how the curve of I want my
career of putting records out to go.
I couldn't,
I couldn't write it any better for me,
you know,
and I get to do,
have freedom to do basically whatever I
want and I'm in play however I want and
I'm saying about whatever I want.
And,
and,
and that's,
it's,
it's the,
it's the greatest thing in the world.
Do you get young guys coming up to her
young girls coming up to you that have
dreams of being a singer songwriter?
Sure.
Asked you for advice?
Yeah,
and my advice has always just be nice,
you know,
be nice,
be nice.
Yeah.
Really?
Well I think that's,
you know,
I think that's always easier than making
too many enemies or you know,
and it,
you know,
the,
you inevitably have people that don't
believe in what you do or thing that's
just,
that's all.
That's a subjective thing.
Of course.
Yeah.
Being nice is important,
but also being you,
be you and be nice,
you know?
And if you do those two things,
um,
I think that's the best recipe to
hopefully,
uh,
for,
for you to put yourself into the
position to get lucky.
Is this something that you had to figure
out yourself?
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
but you know,
when you start and I don't know how it
works from your end,
what you do when you start and when you
get your first little,
you know,
I get a publishing deal and then you get
to be around some of what an industry is
and then you slowly but surely get to
meet people who are successful in
different facets of it.
And I think what I find is the people
that I,
that I gravitate towards and that I
really respect and look at it and go,
hey,
I career like that would be nice.
You know,
they're very nice,
you know,
caring,
giving the individuals who,
who support younger artists and they um,
you know,
they do nice things for the community
and they do nice things for people out
in the world and um,
and they make music that's in their
heart and those are the,
those are the things that
I think are,
are good to aspire to as a musician.
And
those are the things I respect.
I respect.
I respect that.
Yeah.
A whole lot.
Not just talented but nice.
Yeah.
Now what about like a work ethic or did
the,
do you have people asking questions
about like how do you motivate yourself
or how do you,
how do you sit down and write?
How do you like,
what's your process?
Uh,
you do as a like what is my advice to
them?
Like I say,
right,
you know,
write as much as you can with as many
people as you can,
find who know what they're doing and um,
that's,
that's how you learn how to write songs.
But I,
you know,
I'll also say you should have a song
writer friend who said,
you know,
you,
you can't,
you can't learn how to be a songwriter.
You can learn how to write better songs
more often,
but it's not,
you know,
it's like,
and,
and I,
and um,
forgive me,
this is a wrong analogy,
but I don't think you can really learn
how to be funny
if you're a comedian.
I used to think that,
I used to think that because I think,
well,
you're the funny or not funny.
And then I realized like,
oh,
some people need to learn how to be
comfortable enough to be funny.
Yeah.
I've met people that sucked and then
they got good.
Really,
really good.
That's.
That's well I'm giving the wrong advice
then because I personally,
I personally think like some of it has
to be innate and then you have to learn
how to sharpen that tool a little bit.
Well,
I think whoever you are can change.
And I think if you are in a position
where you are incapable of writing songs
or incapable of being funny or incapable
of writing books or doing paintings,
whatever it is,
it's because of whoever you are right
now,
but that doesn't mean,
and whoever you are right now is who
you're going to be five years from now
or whatever.
I think if you can go enough personal
growth and enough introspective thinking
and objective realization of your
environment and then the way you
interface with people slowly but surely
changes and evolves and matures your art
will your,
your expression well,
because you're not who you are.
You know you're not who you were five
years ago.
You're not who you were 10 years ago.
Okay.
This is my thought.
I mean,
it doesn't.
I don't think it works with everybody.
There's some people that just aren't
fucking funny.
Don't get me wrong.
But I used to think that there was just,
if you sucked in the beginning,
you're going to suck.
And then I met
people.
There will be some spark,
spark or drive,
you know,
like,
uh,
I think if would you say that if the
person that was trying to be funny was
not funny at first,
they at least knew that they weren't
funding and had to get better at it?
No,
no.
Sometimes they think they're funny and
then they become funny and select is.
I used to think that there was much more
of a clear defined pattern then I think
now.
Um,
but I think it's about being clueless.
I think cluelessness is the enemy of any
real.
Anything that you're going to make
that's going to have a real impact on
people.
If you're,
if you're clueless,
have you done.
Don't see how people perceive you.
If you're not aware of how they're
taking you in,
when you're communicating with them,
your art is gonna suck.
Like you don't have a connection with
them.
You don't have a connection with people,
you don't have a connection with
yourself.
I think unless there's some sort of a
solitary thing that you do,
like maybe maybe sculpting or painting
like can be a madman is like totally
like in your own world and create some
crazy art form that someone can come
along and look at and go,
wow,
but anything where you're interacting
with people,
I think there's a big part of that
interaction is the way you look through
other people's eyes and the way they
take in what you're saying,
not just what you want to get out,
but also you are recognition.
Some sort of either peripherally or
whether it's,
uh,
obviously your,
your realization of how they're
perceiving your thoughts and ideas and
what,
what vehicle you're delivering these
ideas in.
Is it clunky and too loud or do you have
the same thought and make it smooth and
calm and sinking into people with the
right words and the right cadence.
And the right,
you can have the same ideas but they
just,
they need a better vehicle to get
through and I think cluelessness
prevents you from objectively analyzing
your own work.
Gotcha.
So self awareness,
self awareness is really important part
and brutal honesty,
you know,
with yourself.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll go with that.
Yeah,
I mean you must have that with songs,
right?
Like do you have songs where you write
and then you go back and what the fuck
is this?
Absolutely.
You know,
but you also have songs where,
uh,
you know,
your rights every day you write a song,
you get done,
you don't get to the end of the day
without thinking that you did something
good,
but it's only on,
you know,
you got to get away from it a little bit
and then like read,
listened to it or reexamine it and go
eh.
Or Hey,
you know that.
So I don't,
I think it's easy to feel like you were
a genius in the moment as a song.
Especially.
We've got a couple of drinks.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Do you,
um,
like how much of the stuff that you
actually write becomes a song that you
publish?
Like,
like say if you're,
if you're writing like how many of the
days spent do you,
does it actually come out to be like a
full song,
a song in three hours?
Really.
But you can also not right spending
three hours,
right?
Yeah.
If I don't want to,
I'm like,
are you asking if there's like a
schedule to.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I mean like how much of it like really,
really connects with you.
Like I'm sure you must be sitting.
Sometimes you sit down and on the first
draft you just fucking nail it.
Right?
You've got an inspiration to me every
time.
No,
but I'm just trying to see if there's
parallels between ca because comedy is
probably 10 to 1:10 things.
I write a bullshit and one thing that my
mom might be something there.
Yeah.
I think.
I think if you're doing,
if you're doing,
if you're doing 10 percent of what you
do is,
is,
is worked at Judeen good enough to put
out in the world.
I think you're probably doing pretty
good.
I mean,
I think that's,
that's a pretty good average,
uh,
of things that are worth something,
you know,
you hope for better,
but that if you're doing that,
I think that's doing your job,
but you got to go.
I also believes you've got to go through
some of the ones that aren't there just
to kind of flush them out.
You have to get the,
you have to get that out.
Otherwise they,
it,
it stuck there and it's gonna mess with
everything I should do.
And just,
just,
you know,
if there's something on your mind to
work on,
work on it to the end,
make it the best you can.
Make it,
then look at it and go,
hey,
was this really something I should have
worked on?
Yes or no?
And then just,
then you can push it out and kind of
move on.
I think that's important to kind of
flush out your,
your mind that way creatively.
Do you ever come back to your stuff like
sort of almost like,
like come back to it when you haven't
thought about it in forever and look at
it with fresh eyes,
like almost like you're collaborating
with somebody else and now I'm very much
the guy who believes like the first
instinct is probably the correct one
most of the time.
Interesting.
I don't like to go back and edit and
edit and edit.
It's not me really.
Yeah.
So when you write a song,
you write a song pretty much.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Does everybody do it that way?
No.
No,
not at all.
There.
There are guys who will take a whole
year to write one song really.
And I can't write with those guys.
I respect them but I don't have that
kind of patience.
I don't.
And they've written some songs that I
think are fantastic and I really do
appreciate it.
Um,
but I,
I,
I'm completely impatient.
Erotic songs.
I feel like,
you know,
my favorite songs are ones that just
kind of fall down out of the sky in a
bolt of lightening.
And you wrote it in about 10 minutes and
you're like,
that's exactly what it was supposed to
be.
Great.
I'm done.
I'm going to go eat a sandwich.
Right.
How much you should be,
right under the influence of something.
I don't like that really,
really to do that.
Nothing.
Well,
I mean I'm going to have a sip of
bourbon or something,
but,
you know,
it's,
I don't like that that much because I
like,
uh,
I like the clarity,
the,
there's a,
you know,
some guys can't do it without it.
And some guys,
it's,
it's like that makes them,
all of the sudden turned into the
Michael Jordan of songwriting,
you know,
but it just,
that's for me,
if I'm going to do something like that,
I,
it's recreational and I'm gonna go eat a
bunch of chips and watch a movie or
something like I'm not going to get.
I'm not going to get any real,
uh,
not much worthwhile.
It's going to come out of that for me.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
It's an interesting thing that people
have this different approach to
essentially w w what's an open ended
creative avenue,
you know,
like creating a song,
it's like a blank sheet of paper and
your,
your idea and so many different people
have different approaches to how to,
how to make that thing come out of their
head.
Yeah.
Well,
and I'm not saying that I haven't tried
many different ways,
but I find for me the process that
clarity works better than,
than,
than trying to alter myself to,
to get to some other plane,
but maybe there is another planet I
don't know about,
but I've never been there.
Right.
I would want,
like George Carlin had an interesting
way,
the real comedy who'd write comedy sober
and then he would smoke a joint,
punch it up.
Well,
yeah.
So he'd write the initial ideas.
You write it all out,
write out the bit that needed.
Okay.
Let's look at this thing again.
Well,
I mean I think that probably works in
comedy.
I,
yeah,
I've,
I've started adopting that.
I used to write almost all high and now
I write 50 percent high,
50 percent sober and then a punch up
high.
Okay.
Yeah.
But not to punch up as can be a term for
editing.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Um,
yeah.
It depends on some styles of writing.
Some guys right in bit form like they
say.
So the other day I walked in,
they would write it out like,
and other guys would just like say
clocks,
like the idea of clocks,
like the arbitrary decision that we all
made that there's,
you know,
these numbers around this dial,
this it's minute is this amount of time
and you'll just start writing all these
different things out of that.
You might write a whole essay out of
that.
You might have one paragraph that makes
sense,
like one quick one liner about time,
you know.
So maybe it's a,
an answer to a pretentious friend and
like there is new time and yeah,
well if you fucking show up late,
you get fired.
It's time for you get a new job.
That could be a way where you could take
time and you know,
just take like this big essay on it and
you would extract an idea that could
eventually be humor on stage,
but everybody's got a different style
that.
Yeah,
you know,
that's a lot of thinking.
Fuck man.
Because all a lot of thinking,
right?
That's why I always love talking to
people that do something completely
different than me.
Like you always want to know like,
okay,
how does a guy who writes books do this?
How does a guy who writes songs do this?
How does it guy who makes movies do
this?
Right.
You know,
because it seems like it's a lot of the
same muscles,
but the.
Then in talking here,
I'm not sure that the processes are
exactly.
I don't know that they always translate.
I think the focus is the same thing.
It's like your whatever your end goal
is,
whatever you're trying to create.
It's all about showing up and doing that
work and staring at it and trying to
figure it out.
And then for,
for comedy,
it's a lot about getting in front of the
crowds.
You gotta you gotTa work a lot.
If you don't work a lot,
it's not going to work,
just won't.
You have to be out there.
You can't just create comedy on your
own.
Whereas I think you with a bunch of
talented musicians,
you could probably developed a fucking
jam and record before anybody ever got a
chance to see it.
And that's what,
that's what you do.
Yeah.
It's clearly different style of
creation.
Although we did,
you know,
we do try things out on the road,
like,
and you kind of get a feel for them
sometimes that way.
So yeah,
we do,
we do some of that.
Absolutely.
But probably not as much as what you're
talking about.
Yeah,
I think it's a different art form.
Right.
Do you ever have,
do you ever do things specifically with
the intention of getting material out of
it?
Like,
like in life?
Yeah,
like go do something.
Like maybe if I go do this I'll,
I'll figure out,
I'll get some songs out of this or
something,
you know,
I don't know that I ever specifically do
something to get material out of it.
But I do do things because something
comes up and I go,
that sounds so weird.
I'm going to go do that.
And then from that,
and then from that,
either good things happen or I have a
story that sounds like it's fake.
That might be the best way to do it.
Right?
To just live a happy,
fulfilled life and mine that happy,
fulfilled life for ideas rather than
chase.
Interesting things with the specific
intention of turning them into
creativity.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think I ever do that,
but I definitely,
I go do things that might make me
uncomfortable or put myself in
situations where I'm like,
this sounds like
the weirdest thing.
I think what,
um,
what,
you know,
the case in point and that turned out to
be a,
you know,
we are now good friends.
But uh,
you know,
the first time I ever met Timberlake,
Justin timberlake.
Yeah.
I got a call to basically play at his
birthday party.
His wife called me
and this is no live,
like he'd seen a youtube video or
something and said,
hey,
would you come play?
And he thought I was getting punked or,
and I was just,
and I was just like,
and the conversation with his wife
Jessie was,
she was like,
yeah,
I'm a,
you know,
there's not a lot of things that he's
done a lot of things.
It's hard for me to find new experiences
for him.
And so I was wondering if you would like
to come play at his birthday party.
So I'm thinking and so this is what you
came up with,
you know,
this,
this realm duty saw a youtube video on
getting him to complete his birthday
party.
And it turned out to be fine and we hung
out a,
you know,
a,
and but it on paper,
it would to me,
it was just like,
this is really strange.
I don't know that this,
I don't know what's going to happen.
Right?
But out of that we,
we've become friends and you know,
done things together and,
and,
and good things have come out of it,
you know.
But there was no intent out of it other
than that than I thought it would be
interesting to go do.
And so I went and hung out and it turned
out to be great.
And we're good friends now and that's
pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
But that.
But that's how we met you to.
Yeah,
there we are.
And I was literally his birthday present
one year.
So that's wild man.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah,
I think that might be the formula.
Just if you can do things that you find
interesting and just have those as being
like
excellent a side side adventures in your
life.
Right.
And,
and you know,
nobody else has to understand it but
you.
And that's,
that's the cool part about it,
you know,
people used to get onto me,
I used to be able to grasp band and
they're like,
why are you spending time being a
bluegrass band?
Well,
out of being in that bluegrass band,
I got a cut on Adele,
right?
So
that,
who would've thought that that was the
ex a plus b equals c formula for that.
They'll be in a bluegrass band and
you'll get a pop cut on the biggest pop
star wars.
Isn't that funny though,
that someone would say,
hey,
why do you want to be in a bluegrass
band?
Well,
they wouldn't say,
hey,
why do you like going fishing?
Yeah.
I don't know if you like it.
I like it.
Why do you like bowling?
Right.
It's interesting to me.
So I'm gonna I'm gonna Follow,
follow that road until it ends or takes
a curve or runs off a cliff.
Do you do anything specifically to try
to enrich your mind?
Do you read a lot or anything?
I'm not a huge reader.
I do play a lot of,
uh,
I just,
I just play it a lot of guitar.
I think that's my thing that I really
kind of internalize on a,
like almost like a meditation.
Yes,
absolutely.
If I'm,
if I'm feeling bad or in a bad head
space,
I'm going to pick up a guitar.
If I'm a,
you know,
that's what I do,
that,
that is,
that's if there's a centering thing,
I'm going to pick up a guitar to get
there for me and I don't know.
I don't know if that's mind
if that's flexing your mind a little
bit,
but it is something,
but I'll,
you know,
uh,
playing the guitars,
one of those things where you never
think that you're ever getting any
better at it until one day you wake up
and you understand something that you
didn't understand and hadn't understood
for the 10 years you've been trying to
understand it and then all of a sudden
you have this new,
you know,
new space to live in on it and then
it's.
And it's the coolest thing in the world
to me,
Whoa,
I know what you're saying,
but I don't know if
you hit a new level,
like,
like you're working out and you're
working out and you're working on your
workout for 10 years and you never get.
You hit this point where like,
alright,
this is the peak of what I have.
And then some day for some unknown
reason,
your body or something,
it makes sense and all of a sudden you
could do something that you could never
do before.
And that's,
that's what planning guitar is.
Do I kind of understand the space you're
talking about and I think that applies
to a lot of different things,
you know?
Um,
is this moving me Animoto Musashi quote
that I like I use all the time.
Once you understand the way broadly you
see it in all things and that,
this,
this place that you're talking about,
like these new level places like that
exists in martial arts.
It exists in comedy.
It exists in writing and exists and I'm
sure it exists in music,
although I don't do music.
I think this thing of this Zen Samurai
thing you're talking about of just like
this constant focus until you reach some
new understanding of the thing and you
don't even know how you're getting there
but,
but you're,
but you're working towards something but
you don't know what it is until you get
there.
Yeah.
And then you get it and you have this
new piece of knowledge or it's a piece
of and it's a new.
All of a sudden you're selling something
new too.
And maybe that's the thing you were
talking about earlier about people who
suck accommodate.
All of a sudden they're,
you know,
like that's,
that's what I get off on is finding a,
finding that,
you know,
and,
and I don't claim to be,
you know,
I'm not like
I don't belong in,
you know,
Gary Clark junior world or anything like
that,
but I do love guitar enough to know that
I'm always playing enough to try to find
that new space to live and that's the
coolest thing the world to me because
I'll never get to whatever.
There's never an end to it.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
There's no perfection.
There's no,
um,
there's never an end to it.
It's just a constantly trying to get
better at doing what you do or being,
being used that trying to make yourself
better.
And that thing seems to manifest itself
more with,
with a singular focus like
guitar.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You have to be like way obsessed with
one thing
and that.
And that's it for me for the most part.
Kristan button.
You're a bad motherfucker.
Thank you for coming on the show,
man.
I really appreciate it,
I've been a been a real joy.
It's a real honor,
man.
Thank you.
Go Buy Shit folks.
It's fucking awesome.
All right,
we'll see you tomorrow.
Bye.